here with reaction Georgia congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor green you know some
people talk about for example wind
turbines contributing to the death of
whales and and and uh bird life Etc in
that case nobody wants to seem to talk
about that
um and then you have this this toxic
chemical mess in Ohio uh in Palestine
that we reported on earlier in the
program and and I don't hear anything
from the new green deal climate alarmist
cult uh about what is an environmental
Disaster by every measure why
well I'm not sure I don't know why AOC
isn't dressed in white and crying for
the dead whales that keep watching on
the beach from wind farms that are being
placed all over the ocean and people are
calling the alarms over how this is not
only killing unknown thousands of bird
species but also causing whales to beach
themselves at record numbers but the
real problem Sean is Pete bootage he's
the Secretary of Transportation and he's
more interested in equity and inclusion
in his hiring practices and Grant giving
schemes and and obviously probably chest
feeding or something like that but he is
rail safety and that's where we have
real danger in our country you see Pete
butterjudge was never qualified for the
job and I believe we need to haul him in
in our committees and start questioning
him over what's actually happening in
his Department because train derailment
is happening every single day and now
thousands of people Birds animals
they're all sick and we don't know the
consequences of this horrible accident
in East Palestine but we have people
like ilhan Omar she wants to you know
crack down on corporate greed when it
comes to rails and the privately owned
sections of rails but really what we
have to do is we have to make sure that
our rails are safe Democrats passed a
1.2 trillion dollar infrastructure Bill
and only 5 billion dollars went towards
rail safety this is a failure it would
have never happened under a
republican-controlled infrastructure
bill and we need to hold Democrats
accountable for this especially Pete
bootage where is the money going
well the money's going to the green New
Deal over one trillion dollars from the
infrastructure bill goes to Green New
Deal programs things like seven billion
dollars uh to convert buses and ferries
to Electric batteries most of that
benefits China because China controls
the electric battery
um in the industry and America doesn't
even compete you see they didn't care
about infrastructure they didn't care
about Planes Trains and Automobiles and
our real infrastructure and our
crumbling Nation they cared about
passing their policies woke policies
like the green New Deal that only make
people like Greta happy and make people
like Bill Gates happy but don't do
anything for the American taxpayers and
these important needs of our
infrastructure correct me if I'm wrong
don't you have to you know pillage the
Earth using big heavy equipment that
uses diesel fuel to mine Cobalt and and
manganese and and nickel to build the
batteries whether they're built here or
in China that's the process and the last
time I checked about 90 percent of our
electric grid which you would use to
then charge your your battery uh after
the you pillage the Earth to get the
materials to build the battery uh isn't
that all fossil fuel related 90 percent
of it
well ninety percent of it percent of it
is Sean but you see Democrats want to
convert that to Green energy and that
the federal lands they have taken more
control over all of these Rare Earth
minerals in the in America and taking it
into Federal controlled lands they don't
want you to mine those lands they don't
want you to mine for minerals they want
to convert US and make us completely
dependent on companies like countries
like China which which completely
control most of the world's rare Earth
mineral mines instead of allowing
American companies to be able to mine it
right here at home or just yeah I don't
mean I didn't mean to interrupt you when
you see when you run into AOC in the
halls of Congress or on the floor of the
house do you ever speak to people that
have these used do you ever have these
discussions in person
I I've tried Sean I actually challenged
AOC to debates multiple times and she
has refused to debate me and I wanted to
specifically debate her on the green New
Deal I wanted to challenge her as a
successful business owner and an
American taxpayer on her ideas that will
completely change the way our country
functions not only with energy but but
in our entire economy but ASC couldn't
do it you want to know why she's chicken
and she isn't brave enough to defend
those ideas because they're not her own
they came out of a think tank and she
just put her name on them and I'm
willing to sponsor that debate and just
sit back and watch the show because that
would be an interesting hour
congresswoman thank you for being with
us we appreciate it hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else